[Aplausos]
buenos días con todos según la onu
según la onu una de cada siete personas
en el mundo vive con un tipo de
discapacidad somos en general una
población sub representada en todos los
ámbitos del desarrollo humano puesto que
la persona con discapacidad a los ojos
de la sociedad representa una carga y
una molestia
y esto es porque para ellos no contamos
con las suficientes destrezas y
capacidades para poder ser productivos
por nuestra propia cuenta y digo somos
porque como pueden ver yo soy una
persona con discapacidad yo nací sin mi
mano derecha
en países en vías de desarrollo hablamos
de más de 2.4 millones de personas con
esta condición sólo en el perú somos
alrededor de 12 mil 600 casos de
personas con amputación ya sea congénita
porque nacieron así o debido a causa de
un accidente
un país en el que el costo de una
prótesis robótica importada puede llegar
a costar 250 mil soles
se imaginan el costo de una mano termina
costando casi igual que el de un
departamento
afortunadamente les tengo una gran
noticia también en el perú venimos
desarrollando tecnología de
rehabilitación ya hemos ideado la manera
de poder llegar a quienes más los
necesitan y se los voy a explicar
para ello voy a comenzar contando un
poco sobre mi historia nacer si mi mano
derecha ha sido un hecho que ha marcado
absolutamente todas las etapas de mi
vida hasta este momento fundamentalmente
de pequeño recuerdo haber visto una
película que fue el inicio de todo todos
recuerdan star wars 5 el imperio
contraataca pues en esta película
recordamos la escena final esta luke
skywalker peleando contra darth vader y
en plena pelea look pierde la mano el
personaje principal se queda sin una
mano pero en la escena siguiente sucede
esto
los droides robóticos los robots médicos
le implanta salud una mano pero que no
únicamente se ve como una mano sino que
es funcional y tiene el sentido del
tacto
eso para mí fue guau yo quiero una mano
como la que tiene luke skywalker
y en serio ese ha sido el sueño que he
tratado de perseguir todos estos años
hasta ahora por eso es que decidí
estudiar ingeniería mecatrónica para
poder realizar este proyecto proyecto
que hace un par de años pudimos
conseguir en el laboratorio de
investigación en biomecánica y robótica
aplicada de la pontificia universidad
católica del perú aquí junto a un equipo
de profesionales de diferentes
disciplinas entre ingenieros diseñadores
industriales fisioterapeutas y
psicólogos es que desarrollamos la
primera prótesis mioeléctrica hecha en
el perú completamente desarrollada
fue precisamente en el proceso de la
recopilación de los datos para este
proyecto que me di cuenta de cuál es el
real problema con la demanda nacional
que existe el ministerio del trabajo y
promoción del empleo reporta un índice
de 40 casos al mes de lesiones de mano
cifra que se ha venido incrementando en
los últimos siete años de manera
ascendente pero eso no es todo porque
estos 40 casos son solamente reportados
por el 30% de empresas formales que
reportan al ministerio pues vivimos en
un país en el que hay un índice de
informalidad del más del 70 por ciento
este escenario constituye el peor
posible para alguien que perdió la mano
en un trabajo por dos factores el
primero porque lo más probable es que se
encuentre trabajando en una empresa
informal y por lo tanto no tenga un
seguro que cubra la prótesis más básica
de todas la de garcía
y además si es que la persona quiere
adquirir una prótesis por su propia
cuenta las de tipo garfio a cuatro mil
soles y manos estéticas sin ninguna
funcionalidad como las de un maniquí a
cinco mil soles para alguien que recibe
un sueldo mínimo o en muchos casos menor
a este representa casi un imposible
es precisamente alrededor de este
problema que empieza a crecer una idea
en mi mente
porque es que la tecnología que estamos
investigando no la podemos llevar a
modelos más accesibles para todos porque
no podemos colocar la tecnología de
rehabilitación en acceso para aquellos
quienes más lo necesitan
y fue así como nace esta iniciativa que
conformó con otros profesionales que se
llaman dando una mano en dando una mano
trabajamos ingenieros psicólogos
fisioterapeutas y diseñadores
industriales para decir prótesis de mano
y dedos que sean funcionales y
personalizadas que permitan la
reinserción laboral de la persona que ha
perdido la mano en el menor tiempo
posible
pero en el proceso de desarrollar esta
tecnología nos dimos cuenta de un
detalle no podíamos hacer la prótesis
únicamente y dársela a la persona porque
no es como un celular se trata de una
herramienta que va a utilizar todos los
días de su vida entonces teníamos que
afrontar este desafío desde dos puntos
de vista
primero el desarrollo tecnológico
obviamente y además compuesto por una
frase por una fase pre prótesis y post
prótesis pero por qué es importante una
fase pre prótesis un poco más sobre mí
creo que podría ayudarme explicar esto
yo nací y crecí en el valle sagrado de
los incas en cusco urbana es un pueblo
bastante pequeño y tenía la ventaja de
conocer casi a todas las personas que
vivían en el mismo sitio que yo entonces
nunca tuve o no recuerdo tener problemas
de bullying en el colegio o pasar por
las calles porque se trata de un sitio
en el que todos nos conocemos el desafío
comenzó en lima
vivimos en una ciudad de 11 millones de
habitantes en el que todos somos
desconocidos y de pronto empecé a darme
cuenta que me incomodaba que la gente me
viera de forma distinta porque nunca
antes había enfrentado algo como eso y
de pronto comenzó a ocultar mis manos en
los bolsillos de las casacas y solamente
me compraba poleras que tuvieran el
bolsillo aquí adelante para andar así
durante todo el día
ahora imagínense el caso de alguien que
durante 30 años de su vida tuvo ambas
manos y de pronto por un accidente la
pierde
absolutamente no solamente se limitan
las capacidades físicas sino también las
emocionales es por ello que es necesario
un psicólogo que nos ayude a entender
antes de darle la prótesis a la persona
si es que ya se encuentra apta
emocionalmente para poder recibirla de
igual manera el fisioterapeuta nos ayuda
a evaluar si físicamente cuenta con
movilidad para poder activar la prótesis
una vez que ha pasado esta fase de
evaluación es que inicia este proceso
tecnológico empleamos un escáner 3d para
escanear tanto la mano sana como la
sección amputada del usuario ello nos
permite tener modelos por computadora
para eventualmente hacer el diseño
paramétrico de las medidas de la mano
que es el diseño paramétrico
afortunadamente todas las dimensiones de
nuestro cuerpo están en función
ecuaciones matemáticas una respecto a
otra
y nos apoyamos de este hecho para que
con las dimensiones del diámetro de un
dedo y su longitud podamos obtener en el
menor tiempo posible el resto de los
dedos de la prótesis la palma y lo más
importante el encaje protésico pues
ningún tipo de amputación en todo este
proceso que hemos visto es distinto al
otro de pronto de la siguiente fue
limpio de pronto fue congénito quizás en
el accidente no terminó quitándose toda
la mano sino simplemente quedándose con
dos dedos únicamente una vez que hemos
diseñado la prótesis empleamos
tecnología de fabricación digital la
impresión 3d entonces todas las piezas
de la mano las colocamos en la impresora
y un proceso que nos podría tomar de 1 a
2 meses termina durando únicamente de 2
a 3 días
una vez que el usuario está con su
prótesis que es lo que procede la fase
post y la fase post es sumamente
importante porque el fisioterapeuta le
enseña al usuario a utilizar la prótesis
en su propio hogar o ya sea donde se
encuentre trabajando y el psicólogo nos
ayuda a entender si es que la persona
está utilizando la prótesis como debería
o para los objetivos en un inicio tanto
el usuario como el equipo se habían
puesto de acuerdo
pero porque se los cuento yo me gustaría
compartir con ustedes el testimonio de
nuestro primer usuario la señora sandra
el nombre sandra kallstrom h a 46 años
ah
i
cuando tenemos psicológicos y antes
cuando yo no sabía que existe proyecto
ni siquiera me lo imaginaba y yo vivía
muy deprimida y no hacían nada no
intentaba ni siquiera éste aprender a
hacer las cosas con lo que tiene
saldrá desde todos los dedos de la mano
tiene la parte carpiano todo este
segmento entonces cuando se quiere
protestar ese segmento y no se encuentra
generalmente en el mercado una prótesis
adecuada
y
y cuando me dijeron cómo era yo desde el
principio los sonidos no te había
mentido sigue con lo vi cómo era pero no
sabía qué movimiento de esta manera iba
a hacer las cosas no me lo imaginaba
ante nada para mí esto es un apoyo moral
no apoyó también económico porque yo no
sé nunca a verme cuando estaba unas
botas pero si me lo decían que era algo
carísimo en fin yo nunca voy a portar
hasta durar menos poder juntar juntar
juntar no sé si hubiera sido de acá tres
años nos animó difícil que está la
situación yo no trabajo no entonces de
esa manera yo estoy bien agradecida con
ustedes por su apoyo la verdad que si
alguien me preguntara a mí que me dijera
lo que está pasando yo le digo yo estoy
un incentivo
porque en realidad no se quiere hacer
estas cosas de poder [ __ ]
invisibles de posiciones eficientes y
ahorita la rabia sus cabellos para poder
amarrar y me adapto sé así que yo quiero
hacer más
yo voy a lograr muchas cosas como si lo
voy a lograr
realmente nunca pensé que la tiene
facilidad con la mano derecha pero doy
gracias de que si no tengo muchas
realidades y estoy aprendiendo más cosas
que de lo que yo pensé pensé que en
realidad pensé que iniciando jamás nada
puedes pegar a mano y nunca va a superar
pero si es una ayuda totalmente ustedes
desde que me han nos hemos conocido ya
no es sentir bien como en familia
entonces yo lo he visto esto como si
ustedes fueran parte de mi familia y no
los veo como extraños y no los veo como
mi familia
[Música]
cuando conocimos a sandra le resultaba
sumamente dificultoso poder compartir
con nosotros el detalle de su accidente
tiempo después de que hicimos este vídeo
junto a ella ella nos mandó este segundo
vídeo
[Música]
recuerdan que les explicaba el vídeo que
su accidente había tenido que ver
necesariamente con el uso de una máquina
de cocina industrial para nosotros es
fantástico saber que ella está
utilizando la prótesis que hemos hecho
con todo el equipo para sentirse
empoderada y volver a enfrentar ello y
una vez más retomar su oficio
son historias como las de sandra las que
todo el equipo de dando una mano quiere
seguir contando lo que nosotros podemos
hacer de aquí adelante es bastante
increíble tenemos pensado por ejemplo de
los plásticos de las botellas que
ustedes toman agua poder realizar las
prótesis porque ese filamento también se
puede reutilizar o hacer velaciones
nivel eléctricas como la primera
prótesis de investigación que hicimos
pero que pueda ser utilizado por
usuarios que tengan un nivel de
amputación mucho más arriba del brazo
son estas las historias que nosotros
contamos y lo que les quiero pedir ahora
es que sean mi voz y sean mis manos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]